Speaker 1: Criminal defense lawyer wrote to
me over the weekend, tears in his eyes, I
could tell, even though it was an email that
the guy was crying as he wrote to me and he
said, David, listen, I'm a criminal defense
attorney.
Where Trump can get himself into real trouble
here is if he has a gag order placed on him
at tomorrow's arraignment, he may not be able
to resist talking about the case, and that
would be considered a bond violation and it
could get Trump rearrested.
The latest news is that a gag order is, quote,
extremely likely at tomorrow's arraignment.
And Donald Trump has scheduled a press conference
for tomorrow evening.
Okay.
So this has this is a secondary story which
has the potential to completely explode into
a very different sort of situation than this
coordinated, very dignified arrest that is
taking place tomorrow in New York City.
Business Insider Report.
Quartz.
Let's go through it piece by piece.
A gag order for Donald Trump is extremely
likely once he's before a judge.
Legal expert says Donald Trump can't seem
to stop talking about his indictment, but
he may have to soon.
It's extremely likely he'll be put under gag
order, one expert said.
Punishment in New York for criminal contempt
could be a $1,000 fine or 30 days in jail.
Such a gag order would say to Trump and others
involved in the case do not speak publicly
about the case.
And yet an announcement from yesterday that
Donald Trump tomorrow will be holding a press
conference about the arraignment in Mar a
Lago.
The announcement coming on Trump Make America
Great Again 2024 letterhead, naturally.
And it says Tuesday, April four, 815 Eastern.
That's tomorrow evening.
President Donald J. Trump, 45th president
of the United States, will deliver remarks
at Mar a Lago in Palm Beach, Florida, at 815.
This is expected to be not only remarks, but
a press conference.
If there is a gag order and Donald Trump doesn't
cancel that event and he speaks about the
case against him.
He would be subject to re-arrest.
Now, I know people are saying 30 days in jail
with Trump.
It would probably be the thousand dollar fine.
Let's be completely honest.
But it would make him subject to re-arrest.
And in all seriousness, none of them were
crying when they emailed me that I know of.
But numerous lawyers wrote to me and said,
This is really where Trump has to be careful.
The next question mark, which I believe is
of utter importance, is whether this arraignment
will
be televised.